[Music]
hey what's up guys mkbhd here and you
know what's exciting
we just started the second half of 2020
and we're expecting a lot more
major releases in just the tech world in
general we saw a lot of minor stuff in
the first half but just in the
smartphone world pixel 5 is probably
coming along with maybe pixel 4a
galaxy note 20 and maybe note 20 ultra
galaxy fold 2
asus rog phone 3
oneplus nord
and iphone 12 just to name a few so this
video
is what i'm hoping for
based on what we think we know about
iphone 12 and what i have here which are
the classic mid-year dummy models of the
iphone that come out that sort of
ideally hopefully represent something
like what we're going to see in the
final version in september so the theme
that i'm going to blanket over
everything we see here is
ipad pro
a lot of the changes and improvements
and additions we're expecting and hoping
to see in this next iphone are kind of
already in the ipad pro one of my
favorite gadgets in a long time but
first thing you'll notice about this
iphone 12 stuff is the sizes there's
three sized models here representing
basically what we'll see as iphone 12
iphone 12 pro and iphone 12 pro max but
this time as you can see the non pro
phone is the smallest iphone unlike
previous years where it was like the
middle size and then the approximate
screen sizes we're looking at here are
5.4 inches 6.2 inches and 6.7 inches now
if you know me you know i'm a big phone
person but i've been using the smaller
iphone lately and i think a lot of
people are going to appreciate this
smallest version
of the iphone 12. it's like the closest
thing to what we've been hoping for
which is a refinement of that old square
design
and 5.4 inches as a screen size
is surprisingly compact and just for
some perspective the the last time we
had a samsung flagship of that screen
size was galaxy s7 so i've always given
out a best small phone of the year and
my smartphone awards at the end of every
year and it seems like it's always just
the smallest iphone versus whoever else
decided to make something like a small
flagship in the past year because it's a
rare thing to do so i have a feeling
it's gonna look the same way this year
with this small iphone and then at the
other end of the spectrum the biggest
iphone is even bigger 6.7 inches is
massive that would be the biggest iphone
ever and also consequently their biggest
battery ever and the most room
internally in any iphone but really i
gotta say after all these ios 14 updates
we got with the widgets and everything
this is probably the phone that's most
likely to to take the biggest advantage
of it this is probably the phone i'm
gonna end up with but if you want a
breakdown of all the ios 14 features
that we have seen link below the like
button it's a lot of stuff and it's i
think one of the biggest updates ever
but anyway here's a little mock-up
thanks to the magic of video editing of
what that huge screen might look like on
iphone 12 pro that's my ios 14 home
screen right now and it's just a massive
canvas for watching videos and gaming
multitasking and all that sweet ios 14
picture and picture stuff plus the notch
does look a little bit smaller when the
screen is a little bit bigger and i
guess that brings us naturally to the
design which you've definitely noticed
by now straight from the ipad pro we got
these squared off flat sides and you
know what that means
it'll stand up on its own without a
stand now
i don't know why that's so satisfying to
me but it's just fun that it does that
uh now i know most people have a case on
their phone but if i can just speak to
the small minority of us who carry a
phone naked who don't have a case on it
and who feel it every day
uh the rounded sides of the iphone
were just a little less satisfying to
hold and these flat sides
are it just feels more secure and just
more confidence inspiring so beyond just
the aesthetics of looking better with
flat sides i really do think like it's
it feels better to have flat sides so
now it inherits that cleaner more modern
ipad pro look
and we're still looking at a pretty
similar camera bump on the back apple
logo in the middle of the phone it's
it's still familiar iphone as we've said
for like the last 10 straight years but
that's what apple does you know they
know being a better but still familiar
version of what they've done for so long
is just gonna work and that's about as
big of a design change as we expect to
see now the notch on the front this is
something the the models can easily get
wrong uh my wish list is smaller notch
just purely for aesthetic reasons but i
also know that to keep face id and to
keep all those sensors means you still
got to keep some kind of notch so i
don't expect it to be a drastic change
until they get rid of it completely that
day may come somewhere in the distant
future when they decide to add touch id
back underneath the glass of the iphone
but generally i wouldn't expect any
drastic change with the notch this year
also you know how last year they said
face id would get faster and work at
more angles
i hope they take another meaningful step
in that direction again this year
because you know it's better by a little
bit but i still even at like a 45 degree
angle have to do that like lean to get
it to see and recognize my face so i
hope that gets better and then these
models are usually pretty accurate with
external dimensions and so if they are
again here these new iphones are
actually pretty thin you know just a
tiny bit maybe a half a millimeter
thinner than current phones but they
just feel thinner because of the flat
sides and just overall the design
reminds me not of the iphone 5s possibly
the most beloved iphone design of all
time but it actually reminds me of
iphone 4 just more of a straight up
glass sandwich that actually lacks the
chamfered edges you know maybe they'll
get that chamfer machine going for lucky
iphone 13. and then you know what else
we can't tell from these dummy models is
the display's refresh rate so number one
item on my wishlist for the new iphones
is a promotion 120 hertz display just
like we've seen on a bunch of other
phones so far this year just like we've
seen on ipad pro rumor mill suggests we
should see it on at least some of the
new iphones
maybe just the pro models
maybe just the biggest one that's
another one of the weird rumors kicking
around right now but i am looking
forward to it catching up and having a
high refresh rate on the new iphone that
port at the bottom probably lightning
again you know as much as i wish they'd
also grab usb type c from the ipad pro
this is one of those things apple's been
the most stubborn about not that there's
anything physically wrong with the
lightning port for most people it's just
usb type-c is better and way more
universal and then let's talk about
these cameras for a second so not
expecting a huge drastic change for the
new cameras but there have been some
lines in ios 14 code dug up that
suggests a couple new features so
currently iphones max out at 4k 60 or if
you want super slow motion 240 fps
that's 1080p but those new lines of code
suggest new iphones will be able to do
4k
240fps
which is just
silly but it's funny i have dedicated
cameras here in the studio that are not
capable of 4k 240fps i think the red
camera is barely capable of that in the
first place
that's just apple straight flex in their
image processing pipeline and their new
performance whatever the new chip is in
the iphone
should be top notch as usual get it top
notch anyway you can see on the models
the smallest iphone the iphone 12 has
two cameras while the pro models have
three makes sense but it also has me
wondering about that lidar remember
lidar on the ipad pro's cameras for
better and faster ar experiences the
question for me when we saw that was
okay is that now required for apple's
vision of the future of ar and if so are
we going to see it in every new iphone
so that's an unknown right now but
that's something to keep an eye out for
as of right now this suggests we won't
have lidar and also another little thing
you see this extra little button down
here on the bottom left corner on this
model what is that it's not the power
button that's still in its normal place
on the top right
so this little extra button which is on
the bottom left of the 12 pro and on the
middle left and middle right of the 12
pro max
is that a fingerprint reader is that is
that a smart connector for some sort of
accessories or wireless charging
accessory my answer is i don't know it
doesn't appear at all in the smallest
non-pro iphone the rumors suggest it's
probably not a smart connector and maybe
just a magnetic charging
accessory or something like that but we
don't have of course the final iphone in
front of us do we so that's some
speculation we're gonna have to keep an
eye on and then 5g this is another one
that you can't tell from the models but
we're expecting 5g to make its way to
the iphone 12 lineup and again it could
have some variety across the line where
we see millimeter wave only on certain
models or we might not see 5g on every
single new iphone 12 that's up to apple
but generally when you get a 5g phone
you're expecting higher prices because
the new modems and higher power draw but
again the biggest phone has the biggest
battery ever in an iphone so we'll see
how apple handles that and then uh a
frosted glass back potentially on the
pro
like as long as we're doing wishlist
stuff if we're just looking at how
reflective if we could have a non-glossy
black
phone
like maybe like a
maybe like a matte black
phone this year
that would be
that'd be pretty sick but anyway that is
pretty much it and honestly taking a
step back i think this new hardware
design combined with ios 14 is
potentially one of the biggest changes
to the iphone we've seen
in a long time and i'm liking a lot of
it again nothing is final it's still
months away this is all a combination of
speculation and rumors and my own wish
list but there's a lot to look forward
to for the second half of 2020 including
iphone 12. let me know what you think in
the comment section below what you're
expecting either way thanks for watching
catch you guys very soon in the next one
peace